resuelve para x y para ella 2 x igual a
14 y por otra parte tengo menos 6 x + 3
igual a menos 42 y bueno quiero resolver
este sistema por el método de suma y
resta o por el método de eliminación y
para eso lo que quiero hacer es eliminar
al agen y para eliminar al ayer lo que
tengo que hacer es poner un 3 aquí y por
lo tanto para poner un 3 aquí lo que
necesito hacer es multiplicar a esta
ecuación de arriba por 3 si yo por una
parte tengo menos 3 james y después
tengo más 3 james y a sumarlo pues estos
dos se van a cancelar y que es justo lo
que yo quiero por lo tanto lo que voy a
hacer es tomarme la primera ecuación y
la voy a multiplicar toda entera por 3
entonces déjame ponerlo por acá esto es
lo que voy a hacer es multiplicar esta
de aquí por 3 por 3 y que me queda bueno
3 por 2 x es lo mismo que 6 x después
tengo menos por 3 es lo mismo que menos
3 bien perfecto pues lo que quería y 3
por 14 3 por 14 es lo mismo que 30 más
12 que es 42 30 más 12 es 42 y entonces
6 x menos 3
42 perfecto y vamos a hacer el método de
suma y resta así que vamos a sumar estas
dos ecuaciones vamos a sumar de un lado
y del otro lado y que me queda bueno del
lado izquierdo menos 6 x + 6 x estos dos
se van y entonces me queda 0 3
menos tres de estos dos se van entonces
también me queda cero y después tengo
menos 42 más 42 y esto también se va y
esto es igual a cero es decir que cero
es igual a cero y es justo en el momento
en el que tú me vas a decir que estamos
hablando de un sistema dependiente este
es la definición de un sistema
dependiente que quería decir eso pues
ahorita lo vamos a recordar pero antes
que nada déjame escribir qué justo esto
es un sistema de pendiente así que bueno
mi solución de estas dos ecuaciones es
un sistema de pendiente y por lo tanto
tenemos una infinidad de soluciones una
infinita soluciones y por qué es eso y
es que si a esta ecuación que tengo aquí
la multiplicó por menos uno pues llegó a
nada que arriba es decir menos 6
x + 3g igual a menos 42 6 x + 3 igual a
menos 42 y esto porque porque bueno sí
yo agarro esta ecuación de arriba y la
multiplicó entonces por menos 3
pues aquí crees que voy a llegar a la
misma ecuación de abajo esto es justo lo
que me decía un sistema de pendiente si
yo puedo hacer que una de las ecuaciones
se vea igual a la otra multiplicando por
una constante exactamente igual y
entonces bueno ya que tengo esta
ecuación vamos a ponerla en su forma
pendiente ordenada al origen 2 x menos
10 igual a 14 otra vez
2x me siento igual a 14 y ahora lo que
voy a hacer es restar de ambos lados de
la ecuación 2x entonces menos 2x menos
2x entonces estos dos se van y me queda
que menos james es igual a menos 2x más
14 pero tengo menos yemen entonces para
convertirla en positivo lo que voy a
hacer es multiplicar por menos uno o
dicho de otra manera pasar el signo y
cambiarle a todos el signo que es igual
a 2x menos 14 y ahora sí vamos a
graficar para entender mucho mejor que
es lo que está pasando
este es el eje de la yeso este es el eje
de las equis y tengo primero una
ordenada al origen de -14 es decir que
en mi intersección con el eje el ayer es
en el punto cero menos 14 y tengo una
pendiente de 12 x por lo tanto es una
pendiente positiva indirecta se ve más o
menos así y ahora lo que quiero que veas
es que no es necesario graficar esta
otra recta porque si graficar amos esta
otra recta que crees me saldría la misma
recta porque es justo lo que te dice un
sistema de pendiente
estamos hablando dos veces de la misma
recta por eso tenemos una infinidad de
soluciones porque todos los puntos de
una recta los comparten la otra recta es
decir que tenemos la misma recta y esto
es lo mismo que te dice el sistema de
pendiente también había otro tipo de
sistemas y vamos a recordar un poco
todos los demás sistemas después
teníamos algo de la forma 0 igual a 1
igual teníamos algo de la forma a ser
igual a 10 igual a una constante era un
sistema inconsistente un sistema
inconsistente te decía pues que estas
dos rectas nunca se interceptaban es
decir que aquí tenemos la misma recta en
la misma línea
mientras que aquí hablábamos de rectas
paralelas cuando tenemos rectas
paralelas pues nunca se intersectan por
lo tanto teníamos un sistema
inconsistente y bueno también no
teníamos los otros sistemas que eran los
sistemas bien padres porque teníamos una
solución y una única solución por
ejemplo este x igual a 1 ya igual a 2 y
este es un sistema completamente
independiente porque curiosamente aquí
tenemos dos rectas y las dos rectas se
intersectan en un solo punto es un
sistema consistente pero bueno entonces
en este problema podemos concluir que
tenemos la misma línea y por lo tanto
pues tenemos una infinidad de soluciones
porque estas dos ecuaciones hablan de la
misma recta